Venezuela's political crisis deepened
this week as the struggle for power in
the country intensifies on Wednesday
president Maduro accused the u.s. of
attempting to orchestrate a coup after
Washington decided to recognize
Venezuela's opposition leader as interim
president one Guido swore himself in as
leader earlier in the day as the country
was rocked by massive anti-government
protests I swear to formally assume the
duties of the National Executive as
president of Venezuela United States
proudly recognized National Assembly
President Juan Y IDO as the interim
president of Venezuela today in
Venezuela the president is elected by
Washington and of course they take
anyone from the street who wants to be a
president we're talking to our
colleagues in Europe and elsewhere to to
demonstrate widespread political support
for the interim presidency I am
committed to international dialogue
today tomorrow and always I'm committed
and personally ready if I have to go and
meet this guy and climb to the top of
man Pico Humboldt at 3 in the morning I
will if I have to go naked
I'll go naked on foot by car by
motorcycle it must be very clear to the
world and to this regime that nobody
will take part in this fake dialog
walkway Jose announcement drew tens of
thousands onto the streets of their
Venezuelan capital it also triggered
demonstrations in support of Maduro
during the week 20 people were reported
killed in the turmoil and a further 500
arrested
Caracas based journalists Norris argot
filed this report this has been received
in Caracas with both joy and rejection
from both parties in both sides of
supporters we are standing right now in
a citizen assembly supporting who on
white oh and of course some of the
National Assembly congressmen but of
course we want to hear the voices of the
people who support and the people who
reject
these calling for elections and the
swearing-in of one white L we're in a
situation never before experienced in
Venezuela so people are coming out
because this is us the Venezuelans it's
not the political parties it's not the
National Assembly it's the Venezuelans
who are coming out and fighting for what
we want the opposition will not return
because we support our president for all
the right reasons for our mission for
our homes for our children they will not
come back all the parties understand
that's coloring buys that matter here
the key thing is to save Venezuela and
that is what we are doing we're starting
the fight this is a government of social
justice our country has many natural
resources natural wealth and there are
many interests that want to get their
hands on it given these obstacles the
governments of Chavez and now Maduro
have made significant progress
another updates to bring cheaper than
the last number of hours or so Nicolas
Maduro has asked the European Union to
drop its demand for a fresh election in
Venezuela now that's as the block
earlier said it would officially
recognize Guido as the country's leader
if another vote is not called the u.s.
also urged the United Nations to
recognize the self proclaimed interim
president but the UN Security Council
while as you're about to see it failed
to reach a consensus here to urge all
nations to support the democratic
aspirations of the Venezuelan people yet
be cool if one of you can tell me in
which article and in which provision of
the United Nations Charter you can find
the legal basis for the self
programmation
it was just this meeting which we've
been forced to attend is yet another
element of u.s. regime change strategy
either you stand with the forces of
freedom or you're in league with Maduro
and his mail the United States is not
behind the coup d'etat it is in advance
it's in the vanguard of the coup d'etat
it is dictating the orders how indeed
can any self-respecting government
possibly justifies supporting the
poisonous regime of the nation
destroying mr. Maduro
anything does represent a threat to
peace it is the shameless and aggressive
actions of the United States and their
allies this discussion in the council is
about the right of the Venezuelan people
to direct their own internal affairs and
choose the future of their own country
democratically just speaking there that
was Donald Trump's controversial chief
of US policy on Venezuela Elliott Abrams
served in foreign policy departments
under presidents Reagan and Bush as well
he was twice convicted of deceiving
Congress over the arming of Nicaraguan
rebels
and he's linked to a coup attempt in
Venezuela back in 2002 against then
leader Gugu Chavez
you